Calling all members of the itty bitty titty committee.
They're not there. I'm not gonna get something that's got wires
and is super uncomfortable
and try to make some shit out of shit that's not there.
So that's why I got these bras from the TikTok shop.
I'm not even kidding. They don't have a wire.
They're super soft and stretchy.
It came in so many colors,
and this is what I like. I don't even like pretending I have boobies.
I'm not gonna wear a bra that even wears these.
I just want something to help with a little bit of coverage
so you can even take these weird shape things out,
and then you just have a nice, soft,
seamless, adjustable little bra. I love it.